hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
today we're taking a look at the Samsung
Galaxy alpha now when I first saw the
commercial for this phone I was first
released by Samsung showing off the
metal build and how it can stand up on
its own on its side and all these other
special things my first reaction and I
even left a comment on the video was meh
I mean it looks like very similar to
other Samsung phones and its might even
look like a mini Galaxy Note 4 or a
slightly improved galaxy s5 but I said
meth because it's so similar to a lot of
other Samsung phones but now it's
officially coming to the United States
which means we're gonna have to take a
closer look at this because this is
going to be showing up in stores right
next to the Galaxy Note 4 and the galaxy
s5 so let's take a closer look at what
makes the Samsung Galaxy alpha different
which means this is going to be a
shorter video because the list of things
that makes the Alpha different from
phones like the galaxy s5 and note 4
it's pretty small but the big focus here
is obviously the material choice and the
feel in the hand that's the whole point
of this phone the whole reason it exists
and the main way they've done that is by
adding a metal band all the way around
the frame of the phone where they use
plastic before so now whenever you hold
the phone you're holding metal and that
makes a really big difference in the way
it feels and that band is chamfered
everywhere it's chamfered all the way
around the power button is chamfered the
volume buttons are separated and
chamfered and they're very clicky the
build of this guy is really really
improved now and actually reminds me of
the iPhone 5s in a lot of ways
everything is chamfered but the thing is
it feels very premium from the front and
from the sides but you flip it over to
the back and suddenly it's the same old
Samsung again it's plasticky soft touch
removable back just like the older
phones and don't get me wrong removable
is great you get access to the removable
battery there's no additional storage
but you know I'm not saying it doesn't
feel sturdy when it's attached to the
back of the phone but the material
itself that you're constantly touching
on the back does not feel nearly as
premium as the metal that surrounds it
it kind of seems confused doesn't like
does it really want to go all the way to
being a premium feel or only go part of
the way and it's actually kind of the
same story with the specs of this guy
actually this was the first Samsung
Galaxy alpha into the United States
completely thanks to 28
check out my Instagram date for proof
and it had some pretty beastly specs so
this is a Korean model it has LTE a it's
an octa-core processor it has 2 gigs of
RAM all your usual sensors gyroscope etc
but then it drops to a 12 megapixel
camera on the back instead of that
new-and-improved 16 megapixel 1 in its
brothers and a 720p pentile display
that's not really as good as other 4.7
inch display phones this display is you
know it's OLED and yes it's very vibrant
and saturated and it does get pretty
bright so it's kind of pleasing but when
you look up close it definitely breaks
down it's not a high-end panel and again
leaves you with this incomplete feeling
about whether it's supposed to feel
fully premium or just partially premium
but that's not going to stop a lot of
people this device is still great still
feels great still looks great
performance is also really smooth when
you combine of course that high-end
chipset high-end graphics 2 gigs of ram
and a 720p display and overall the
software experience is very similar to
the galaxy s5 you've probably already
seen it has a very similar feature set
as well I really like the size of the
phone very good fit in the hand with a
4.7 inch display since it's a bit
smaller than the iPhone 6 thanks to its
thinner bezels so it's clearly not a
full-on flagship phone it has an 1860
milliamp hour battery and a battery life
similar to the Moto X and it's not a
flagship with the slightly bumped down
12 megapixel camera even though
megapixels don't mean everything it's a
older sensor but yet it has all these
other nice specs and this really really
big emphasis on the quality of the build
this premium feel in the hand and you
know it'll compete with top of the line
phones it's almost like a hybrid between
the high-end super premium stuff and the
Samsung feel of last year almost like a
bridge between these two and honestly
this phone gets me more excited about
the Galaxy Note 4 than it does about
itself so at the end of the day the
Alpha is definitely an improved phone no
doubt it's significantly better feeling
in the hand I would say then the galaxy
s5 and I think it's probably one of my
favorite phones just to hold in general
something about that 4.7 inch screen
size also appeals to me a lot but at the
end of the day my reaction is still met
because like I said it's so similar to
these other phones and I happen to like
big phones so I'm going to get my hands
the Galaxy Note 4 very soon anyway and
probably do a video on that ranting a
little more about how I love the metal
so much but either way that's my my
review of the Samsung Galaxy alpha hope
you enjoyed it thank you for watching
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
bass